so when i made that comment about she's
changed this game way
i mean
i love her for who she is and we can
always do something about her weight
gain it's not like i am mad or i'm angry
if that is not even something that would
disturb me if you love somebody it's not
just about the size you know me
[Music]
it looks so good
she's chase she's getting weighed but
it's not about how she looks
emily and kobe
you two are 90 day newbies
whose idea was it for you to join the
show
so neither of us even watched the show
we i'd like i've heard of it but i've
like never watched it um one of my
friends chloe
was like your story's insane
i'm going to reply you guys for 90 day
fiance so it's like okay like whatever
you know i'm from salina kansas like
stuff doesn't happen like that in our
town
um so she like
did everything filled it all out and
like
i don't even know six months later we
got a phone call from new york and i
almost ignored it but i was like
and um it was a talent rep for uh yeah
the talent scout i guess for 90 day and
she was like hey like we're so
interested in your story um like tell us
more about you guys and
kind of took off from there and here we
are well have you catched up on 90 day
at all to kind of get the gist of how
the fandom is and all of that
yeah i mentioned it in like a month like
literally every episode i watched it
with my parents and then i was like
oh my gosh like this is a huge
television show like we had no idea
kobe how do you feel i mean the whole
world is about to know about your
relationship people from cameroon we
don't really know about that except
let's say people were abroad like like
cameroonians in the u.s were into the
show
and knowing that okay there's gonna be a
friend marina in the show which is me
and
somebody like you know just tell me when
it's gonna be edge we're going to watch
it we want to watch it because we it'll
give you all the supports and stuff like
that yeah
but you got you got to represent right
which i'm sure you will
yeah i'm sure you will met kobe we're
actually having a girls night
and i looked over my shoulder and i saw
this you know guy in all white he was
like getting on emily spoke about in the
premiere that she met you at the club in
china and it was an instant attraction
how did you feel when you saw emily for
the first time
she saw me first yeah yeah
so i was dancing i didn't really realize
you know a bunch of girls over somewhere
staring at us dancing and i was done
dancing and i'm like let me go eat
myself the bathroom and then you know
somebody was right behind me yeah i
followed him to the bathroom so i'm like
all right
how are you she said she's good and she
was like where you from
i'm from africa she's like were you from
africa like from cameroon i mean she was
hot
and i'm like yeah and i when i i
actually like where you from she said
she was from the us i'm like okay easy
easy
what is that supposed to mean kobe i'm
from the us too
like all right you know it's not easy
forget to approach you my culture where
i come from like if a girl could
approach you this means a lot
whatever he probably was in one night
yeah obviously he liked that one night
because look where we are right
right
easy
you asked me a question about my first
you know okay first step
me and my mommy like all right one night
stunt easy stuff maybe you thought
maybe i thought you were easy i don't
know now you have a full-on beautiful
baby boy and a life together so hey
yep
all right well kobe you're an
international underwear model or at
least you were at a point in time i was
doing modeling like with suzanne and
stuff like that and an agent proposed to
me like wow you have a good view though
i feel like you know you can be a good
fit but on the way modeling i'm like you
sure she was like yeah and then that was
how like she asked me to take some like
we went to the photograph studio and
took some shots and
that was how i got into the game
yeah i was like how do you become an
underwear model i know it's a thing but
i didn't know the process
i love black guys so of course i found
the only black guy in china you love
black guys and you are unapologetic
about it kobe what are your thoughts on
that
she knows for what you want that is
something that i love about her
and she has a strong like whatever she
wants she's gonna go for it no matter
the arts and stuff like that we just i i
always admire a girl who fights for what
she wants you know
mm-hmm
you say emily that was sweet
yeah oh well emily you grew up in a
small town in kansas so my initial
thought just honest conversation here
when did you realize you were into black
guys because i'm sure the population
here is it's pretty
it's pretty low
yeah it's pretty low um
my
first
like real boyfriend was a black guy like
our my high school we had like i think
two black guys like not that many at all
um i don't know i was just always
attracted to them you know i like
they're so hot you know so i just
saw kobe and i was like oh he's my type
like big arms like that is my type so
like in high school you know once i
started dating like my first boyfriend
yeah he was a black guy and it was just
what i go for you know yeah yeah well
speaking of your small town your
hometown in kansas what were some of the
concerns you had about kobe moving from
cameroon to kansas
so
one of our phone calls kobe was like oh
yeah when i get there like i'll just
walk to like the african store and buy
my pizz
and i was like okay first of all
like you can't walk anywhere from our
house
and second of all we do not have a
cameroonian store and you're gonna have
to like
order your spices because they're
nowhere to be found here um i was
worried like you know it would be a big
adjustment for him and you know he came
from africa where it's probably or not
probably it's but like it is like and
easily yeah like you get what you want
and you're surrounded by like black
people and you come to
the lineup and you know the first place
we went he's like i'm the only black guy
here i'm like yeah big you know shock
for him
um
and i was really worried that i was
going to be his only friend here i was
kind of like
you know sad for him because when he was
in cameroon he was with his friends all
the time like literally every time i
called he was like at a friend's house
or out with friends and then coming here
i'm like wow you're really gonna like be
in dad mode like you're not gonna go
anywhere we don't have clubs in my town
like we don't have your spices i was
really nervous yeah what about you kobe
what were the thoughts going through
your head
um
you know she first told me that it's a
small city it's not that big and
i did my research my findings and
somebody told me like man dude kansas is
a white state i don't know how you're
going to come over here
i'm like wow it's not just kansas it's a
smaller city in kansas which is
almost i'm pretty sure approximately 100
white so no blacks
i was already thinking on how i was
gonna cope but so far i mean
it's a beautiful experience it's a
beautiful place to start a family so
i i'm not regretting you know starting
in salina
even the fact that we could have this
conversation you know and it's open and
it's real it's i love that it was really
emotional when my son was born
you're crying but you're happy but
you're crying because his dad's not here
well kobe unfortunately you weren't able
to be there for cobin's birth
um your visitor visa was denied
i could imagine how you felt but i just
want to hear it out of out of your mouth
what were some of the feelings you were
feeling knowing that you were missing
out on this monumental moment
um
i felt bad that he motive
i didn't get the visa first the visitor
visa that i applied for the first time
and
i've always wanted to be there
see during the
breath of my child but i didn't make it
so part of me fell back honestly
speaking but still i couldn't do
anything but
she
i am saying i could say she's she's been
very very supportive of our relationship
she's been everything i wasn't there
she carried the load all by herself you
know sometimes when ladies are pregnant
you know they need somebody
i mean you can betty pelican stuff
but still
i really i appreciate her a lot
i can't say much but she
she's whatever thing though
yeah
emily you did say he was sweet i see it
i get i get it he says yeah he's the
nicest guy i've ever been with like
it still blows my mind that i met him in
china at a bar and like
thank god he is as great as he is
because i could have ended up with
someone you know
totally opposite of him and i like to
the today i am mind blown like i just
try to be real like
i know but it's who you are though this
is who i am i have my philosophy i try
to do things that if you do the same
things to me i won't get offended you
know
yeah this is jersey even though
sometimes you try to create
which is normal that's just how
relationships we just normal yeah yeah
the love is there though it looks so
good
she's chased she's getting weighed but
she's not about how she looks
kobe you made a statement about um when
she asked you or something you said oh
yeah she's gained some weight
can you i know you kind of regretted
that or you wish you would have said
something differently
i said it was like
you know it's a cultural difference kind
of thing and besides even before coming
over she kept you know bugging me like
you know i'm getting wet and stuff like
that so
i understand this is if you gain weight
is because of the baby
and weight thing
can always be worked upon you you know i
mean like you can always do something
about your weight if you want
the weight to go away so that is not
even something that would disturb me if
you love somebody it's not just about
the size you know i mean there's so many
things that come so size where it should
be the list of the things so when i made
that comment about she's changed this
game way
i mean i love her for who she is and we
can always do something about her weight
gain it's not like i'm mad or i'm angry
and besides for us back home
if somebody said you you've gained
weight it's like sound of good living
you know you're living a healthy life
i figured that i didn't i didn't get the
gist that you thought it was a negative
thing well and i mean he wasn't wrong
like
wait you know it's not like
i was a size six when i you know when i
met him like i had our son and
not every woman drops their weight
immediately and nor should they have to
i feel like i'm getting comfortable you
as a man you have to understand the
sacrifices that you know
a woman is made especially in getting
that weight so you have to make her get
confidence in herself you know i mean
most women after getting weight they
have like kind of stuff like low seven
steam but as a man you need to figure it
out on how you can do the boss hamarasa
you know despite the fact that she's
gained weight so i try as much as i can
make that happen with her can we take a
moment to just give kobe a ride
[Music]
i know look at this man so he can't work
for 90 days right like six months
oh six months i'll get married at 90.
okay i'm picking up the tab for six
months i mean he's just i'm i'm
supporting everybody for six months
right yep
all right well emily your dad is super
nice and supportive he said that he was
okay with supporting you kobe and cobin
until kobe can work
kobe
how did you feel hearing that emily's
dad was willing to do that
and that was like a blessing first of
all
him accepting me to leave in this house
without even knowing me
it's a plus i mean
i don't know what i can say but i'm just
so grateful that
i come i came into this family
maybe this is the right thing of the
year
maybe maybe this is the right family it
is the right family yeah it's still
crazy to me that i'm like i brought this
guy over from africa my parents had
never met him before and they're like
yeah he can live in the house with us no
problem we'll support him no problem
i'm like
that's insane you know
that proves our love for you
you know
oh yeah like the wild child like let me
tell you did not even surprise anybody
i told them that
your dad had one condition when it comes
to supporting you and kobe which is
that you can't get pregnant again
one thing's for sure
you better not get pregnant okay
damn babe you're ready
i can't even believe we are doing a
pregnancy test right now
oh my god
we see that there might be a pregnancy
scare so what can you tease about that
well
you will have to just watch
and see what happens
okay let's just say you know after two
years we could not keep our hands off
each other clearly
yeah we'll just leave it at that
okay okay okay well 90 day fiance fans
are very opinionated
have you mentally prepared
yourself for for the opinions that are
going to come your way
yeah i mean we knew going into this when
we decided to be on the show that
there does come a lot of
haters you know a lot of critique a lot
of people who have an opinion to say
um about people they don't even know
so at the end of the day you know we've
talked about it multiple times we're
happy with our life people who have
comments can have their comments and you
know enjoy
their life and
we don't need to respond to them we're
real people
you know we
we'll just take it everyone else says
who's on the show and that's just that
comes with it so
yeah speaking of that have you met any
of the other couples on this season
no we have not we haven't met anybody
not yet do you have any anything that
you regret doing or might have done
differently before you know
looking back now that might pop up this
season
i would have worn more makeup
i've never tried a number of times oh we
were very very real on this show i know
there was a lot of comments
like oh it's scripted oh it's that and
it is 100
not scripted and what you see is our
life and
for us you know to be vulnerable and to
show up and show you you know
like this is our life this is who we are
and you know i don't wear makeup i i
don't get up every day and put makeup on
and
so i was very real on the show and so
you know what you see is what you get
and that's just us
yeah yeah and i kept telling her that
listen
people just sit behind a computer or
your phone and message you some crazy
stuff don't let that get into your head
that's from africa we've been through a
lot so yeah stops from the internet it
doesn't really you know okay but let me
tell you one thing
like i'm not even gonna read the
comments whatever like the day
the trailer came out because it's like
did you read the comments did you get on
facebook
get on the instagram and read the
comments i'm like no
you need to read them i was like just
laughing because most of those coming
they were like roasting me out how could
you say he's getting away 20 minutes
and then you're complaining about the
weight yeah
i will send you back
i'm like but it was just funny because
you know he's the one
every comment when i'm like i don't even
care to read them because what's it
gonna do and he's like did you check the
facebook page i'm like no i don't need
to check the facebook page
that is hilarious so kobe are you sure
you're gonna be good you're you're
acting as if you are but are you gonna
be
i am super yeah
i
i you know it's kind of like fun you
know
seeing comments about you something that
this is not who i am so it's just fun i
mean
kept me all night just reading and
laughing and laughing and laughing and
laughing and stuff like that you know i
got people who were saying
no that's bad and people were saying you
know this is kind of like a cultural
difference yeah yeah
and it doesn't mean what he you guys are
thinking so and somebody said oh sorry
like
responded somebody's coming and say
sorry um life just not only evolves
around american culture you got to stick
that in your head right now
what do you want fans to know about you
or your relationship before we get knee
deep into the season
anything you just want to make clear set
straight
yeah you know i
once again saw a lot of comments where
people meet just to be on the show
copy and i didn't even know about the
show
like we didn't watch the show we didn't
know about the show we really did fall
in love in china and like this is a very
genuine relationship that throughout the
season you'll see you know has its ups
and downs like all relationships do so
um this is like i've said 100 real and
it is who we are and
we do love each other and i think i love
her you know
driving me crazy okay well feeling
mutual he drives me freaking crazy so